hey audio friend Graham here from
recordingrevolution.com today I want to
show you how to quickly mix an acoustic
song performance where you've played the
acoustic guitar and sang vocals at the
same time if you've caught the previous
two videos I showed you how you can
record your own guitar and vocal
performance with one microphone and how
to do it with two microphones should you
so desire and I've got both versions of
those recordings in front of me today
and I'm going to show you how to mix
both so you'll be well equipped to do
either one so let's start with the One
mic performance which is this blue track
here this was when I literally had one
microphone capturing the whole
[Music]
thing and so what we want to do is take
this hopefully well balanced recording
and enhance it so I'm going to use a
couple of tools that are available to
you in your software and again I'll make
mention here I'm using a free piece of
software to mix this this is called
Protools first it's absolutely free
download so you can do this with free
stuff and I'll use the free included
plugins um to do it the most important
thing you can do is use something called
an EQ to sort of filter out the
frequencies that don't sound so great
either in your room or just that were
captured that day on the microphone to
give a more tonally pleasing performance
let's start there I'm going to grab an
EQ here Seven band EQ this is kind of
your standard um Daw style EQ digital EQ
that you're probably looking at in most
of your software this has seven points
you can do boosts or Cuts it's five main
points and then two filters one on the
top end one on the low end and what I
like to do is just listen listen to the
the performance and then start sweeping
around with extreme boosts in the low
mids the mids the high mids and find
where there's a lot of energy in a
negative way and maybe scoop some of
that out so let's just take a listen and
I will be playing around with this and
then we'll address what I
[Music]
did take me on a crazy
ride give me more than I can
handle I want to see you
Wilder show me more I can so there's a
lot of energy there that just starts to
compound in a negative way that's around
225 um so I think I will cut some of
that out so let's cut
out few DB of that about three we'll see
if that's too much I'll make it a little
tighter all right let's keep going here
I see
[Music]
Wild show me more than I can
handle
take me on a crazy
ride give me more than I can
a a lot of energy there it just sounds
really honky that was at 1K Let's uh
let's take some of that
out I'll 3db of
that let's keep
going Wilder
side show me more than I can he
and take me on a crazy
ride give me more I
hand to see
Wild ah punishing about four and a half
K so I might scoop out some of that
um let's see what we got so far take me
on a crazy
ride give me
more
to what I might do is try to boost a
little bit in the lows just to fill out
some of that bottom end so I'm going to
turn this into a shelf boost excuse me a
notch boost away from a shelf and try to
give a little bit more low-end weight
here just to fill out the guitar take on
a
czy give me more than KN can
hando I want to see you Wilder
sight show me more than knocking
down I need to wake
up all right I need a taste
up there's a life that's joy
unspeakable and full and then I did a
little shelf boost there which around
was almost 6K open up some of the top
end machine now let's see if this is any
doing anything let's see if it's helping
at all so I'm going to press play and uh
bypass the EQ we've done three Cuts two
boosts see if we're helping take me on a
crazy
ride give me more than I can
hand I want to see you Wilder
side show me more than iock can
end I need need to wake
up all right I need a taste
[Music]
[Applause]
up all right not a drastic Difference by
any stretch but I think a more
presentable difference I think it's a
little more cleaned up so the
frequencies are a little more neutral
and not as harsh and it's a little
Fuller in the low end and a little more
AA up top very simple stuff so we'll
start there next thing I'm going to
probably use is a compressor the uh the
point here is
to even out the Dynamics of the
performance a little bit it's hard when
you got a vocal and uh an acoustic
guitar sometimes the vocals will come
and it'll make the mix louder and then
you don't hear the guitar as much and
when the vocals aren't singing and you
hear the guitar you kind of want that to
be brought up a bit this will sort of
even out some of those Peaks and valleys
and give a more upfront performance so
what I'm going to do is just keep it
real neutral in general here I don't
want to be anything squashing or
aggressive so I'm going to have sort of
a faster release U so let's go quickly a
slow attack 10 milliseconds I'll leave
it there I can go slower from there um I
might do 2: one
ratio and then let's um let's dial the
threshold all the way up to zero so it's
doing no compression and I'll start to
dial it down and look for a little bit
of gain reduction and adjust from there
take on a
crazy give me more than I can and oh
I want to see Wilder
sight show me more than I can
Ando I need to wake
up all right I need to
tast there's a life and joy
[Music]
unspeakable and full to the
t
w I need a wake
up all right I want to take
St this all right so what I'm doing
there is I saw about 3db of gain
reduction on the loud Peaks that was
this meter here and um so that's turning
down the mix when it gets louder and
then I'm using the gain knob to bring
back up the whole track a little bit
more about one and a half DB so that the
input and output Peaks are about the
same what that's going to do basically
is bring up the acoustic guitar when
it's quieter in this part of the song um
and quieter in between hits and give a
more upfront consistent volume to
everything so we can do is bypass it and
see what that's doing
take give me more than I can hand
oh I want to see Wilder
sight show me more than knocking and oh
I need to wake
up all right I need a
[Music]
[Applause]
taste again subtle but if you're
noticing on good speakers or
headphones it's like when there's a gap
in the singing the acoustic guitar lifts
up a bit more and so what that does is
it it balances the vocal in the guitar a
bit since we can't balance them it's one
track it was One Mono track I can't turn
up the acoustic or turn down the vocal
the compressor is kind of doing that for
us giving a more even performance all
right and the final thing I'm going to
do is add a little bit of Reverb so what
I might do here is um instead of putting
it on the track which would be a simple
way to do it I'm going to create a new
track
new
stereo Ox
track and I'm going to call this Reverb
which is an appropriate name I'll solo
that as well
and then what I want to do is put the
Reverb plugin on this
track and we'll do
is sure let's start with a hall why not
um I'll leave it default settings we'll
play with it what I need to do is is use
a send on my mix here to
send some of this track let's just pull
up the fader a little bit there send
some of that
to um this Reverb track so I'll make the
input the same bus
one so actually I need to make that bus
one and two not one it's a stereo
bus so if you follow what I've done I've
I'm using this little send to send a
little copy along this bus over to the
Reverb unit so that way I'll have the
full volume nice dry signal here we
won't lose any of that or blend that
we'll keep that and then we'll add a
little bit of this Reverb so let me
um just take a listen to what this
sounds
like sorry solo here take a
czy more than I can
hand I want to see you Wilder
[Music]
side so I'll use room too I've got to
crank just so I can hear it and then
it's got some filters it's a high
frequency cut so I can roll off some of
that top
end and um let's see what that sounds
like let's roll off
more and then I'm just going to dial
this down a bit take me on a crazy
ride give me more than I can
hand I want to see you
Wilder and let's take a listen to it in
a quiet
[Music]
part take me on a crazy
ride give me more than I can
handle to see
Wild all right so let's see what we've
done so far on this one track I'm going
to bypass uh the
plugins and then I'll buy including the
Reverb we'll see where we've
come a crazy
ride give me more than I can hand
oh I want to see you Wilder
side show me more than I can
end I need to wake
up all right I need a
tast there's a life that toy
unspeakable and full to the
top much better right it's a more full a
little more forward and then that slight
room Reverb gives it a some stereo width
cuz it has none and be a sense of space
that is better covering up the the
little room that I'm in so that's how I
would approach a one track
performance now let's approach the two
tracks which was a separate deal so this
is where I recorded it in a separate
video with two different microphones so
I have a little bit more independent
control of the two take a listen to what
these guys sound
like
[Music]
take me on a crazy
ride give me
[Music]
more and here's just the
acoustic so you can tell that obviously
I can hear still some vocal in that mic
but not as much and then here is just
the
vocal take me on a crazy ride
give me more than I can
handle oh I again so still some bleed in
there but a lot more separation and then
we can address them independently so
let's do that let's work on the Guitar
let's say knowing that whatever I
booster cut on the guitar is going to
affect the vocal a little bit the bleed
is there so it's important to keep in
mind we don't want to do anything too
drastic so with the guitar by itself
let's grab an
EQ
and uh let's see if we can clean this
[Music]
up more
I I want to see
you very similar place to the other
track it sounds like that guitar just
had a lot of boxiness there around 212
so we'll take out some
there
give me more than I can
handle oh I want to see you
wild show me more than I can
handle I need to wake
up all right I want to
taste
this frequency kind of sounds like a
cheap guitar to me um whatever that's a
very subjective terminology but you know
you've all played those really really
affordable Acoustics that we first got
into and so I'm going to take some of
that
[Music]
out me more I
hand that just kind of opened up the
acoustic a bit so let's see what we've
done here two cuts one one
[Music]
boost yeah a little more clarity there I
like that um let's compress it because
the the reason here would be a little
different than it was on the previous
track I'm not trying to even out the
vocals to this I'm just trying to even
out the strumming pattern on this
acoustic and just make it a little more
[Music]
strummy knock
hand I want to see you
wild show me
I I need to wake
up subtle but a little more sense of
urgency and a little more upfront and
the volume is going to bring up the the
quiet parts so so far let's bypass the
EQ and
[Music]
compression better now let's work on the
vocal
here grab an EQ see if we can clean up
any weird frequencies here take me on a
crazy
ride give me more than I can
handle oh I want to see you Wilder
side show me more than so there's that
same frequency as that the acoustic
guitars had problems with in the vocal
mic I'm going to see if I can pull some
of that out um and see if that doesn't
hurt the vocal but cleans it up a bit
take me on a crazy
[Music]
before yeah it sounds about the same so
I'm not hurting the vocal let's keep
[Music]
listening give me more than I can
handle oh I want to see Wild it's like
distorting at like 9:20 let's take out
some of that it's overloading the mic
bit tighten that up a
bit all
right
right give me more than I can
handle or to see
Wild 2.2 let's take out some of
that all right let's do a little bit of
a highpass filter on this to roll off
any lowend
um that the acoustic might be filling up
there I don't think it'll be much but
let's
[Music]
see give me more than I can
handle oh I want to see
Wild all right I'm going to do a little
high shelf boost at the end take on a
CRA more I
hand now that's going to open up the top
in that's nice so uh then let's just um
just give a little bit of a boost here
it's a little quieter take on a crazy R
let's bypass it give me more than I can
handle oh I want to see you
wild much more pleasant all right and a
little bit of compression to even out
the vocal performance
here same compressor let's um let's go
for see maybe 3db of gain reduction
take I can
handle oh I want to see you Wilder
side show me more than I can
handle I need to wake
up all right I want to taste
of this long
Joy
unsp go back to the louder Parts take me
on a
crazy that's what I'm looking for the
Peaks I want the output Peak to be about
the same as the input Peak um at its
loudest point take a
CRA mute it or bypass I should say take
a crazy
ride with take me on a crazy ride
so that should keep it about the same
volume but now the quieter part should
be a little louder
take as opposed to this take me on a
crazy take me on a
crazy just a little bit louder so let's
bypass the EQ and compression on the
vocal see what that was doing take
cide give me more than I can handle
oh I want to see you
[Music]
wild all right now what we really have
to do is listen to these two together
because that's the way they're going to
be heard and so we might have affected
each other so what I'm going to do is
I'll start it here and then I'll bypass
the EQ and compression on both
[Music]
tracks give me more than I can
handle oh I want to see you Wilder
side show me more than I can
endle I need to wake
up all right I want to taste St right
more clean more open and then the last
thing we could do is use the same
Reverb we can send we can literally do
here in Protools is just copy same send
that we used on the previous version
version so I'm sending a little bit of
the guitar and a little bit of the
vocals and now we have independent sense
we can send more of the guitar into the
Reverb or more of the vocal or vice
versa and we can take a listen to what
that sounds like as well
take give me more than I can
handle oh I want to
see right so now now they're in business
let's bypass everything we've done eq's
compressors and the Reverb on this
performance take
crazy give me more than I can
handle oh I want to see you Wilder
aside show me more than I can
handle I need to wake
up all right I want to taste St
there's life that's joy
unspeakable and fall to the
top
oh I need to wake
up all right I
[Music]
taste and what's cool is if you do have
the vocal separate from the guitar you
could then experiment with sending the
vocal to let's say a delay could be a
slapback delay could be a longer more
obvious ping pong delay where the vocal
can have that effect and it won't really
be on the guitar the guitar can sound a
little more clean and normal so that is
one of the benefits of having the two
channel performance because you're a
little more control over the effects and
of course we didn't even touch the
faders I felt like we had a pretty good
balance of the two but I could turn the
guitar up or down uh versus the vocal up
or down as well and that will give you
some more control in the mix so
hopefully that gives you a picture of
really what you're doing when you have a
very simple One mic or two mic acoustic
and guitar performance to mix it you're
just using EQ to clean up frequencies
compression to even out performances and
Reverb to give a sense of space that
might sound better than your room and
give you some stereo width because you
have none when you do it this way now
there's a lot more that could be said
about the recording process the mixing
process uh even mastering we didn't even
talk about how to master these tracks
and just put them a little bit more
Radio Ready polish on it as it were and
uh I want to give you some tools that
will really really help you in your
journey because I don't know if you just
caught this video and you haven't seen
the other videos but one thing I can
give you right now that will help you in
your journey is a guide of put together
it's called My Radio Ready song guide
it's about six steps long there's six
main areas that I teach on and recording
is one of those areas mixing is one of
those areas there's four more and I want
to give you this guide absolutely free
because what it can be for you is like
like a companion resource to any of
these videos or anything you're working
on in your studio if you have an idea
for a song and you want to get it out
there in the real world and you want it
to sound good this gives you the map to
do that so download your free guide it's
really easy to get just go to Radio
ready guide.com I'll put the link here
in the video and down in the description
box and it's a free pdf super simple I
keep mine on my phone I reference it
literally to see what I wrote you can
print it up if you're old school and
keep it by your computer where you mix
either way it's chalk full of tips
techniques resources and kind of a map
to walk through anytime you want to
release a piece of music so check that
out at
ru.com as always subscribe to the videos
if you like them and leave me a comment
below let me know if this little
miniseries has been helpful to you I
hope to hear some of your recordings and
I hope that it gets you making music and
having more fun which is the whole point
of this thing anyway I'll see you on
another video real
soon